there is a new warning from the federal
government about possible copycat terror
attacks following last month's standoff
at a texas synagogue in which the
suspect died and the hostages
fortunately escaped unheard
the department of homeland security says
supporters of foreign terrorist
organizations have encouraged similar
acts of violence our senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge has more
according to the homeland security
bulletin after the texas synagogue
standoff homeland security analysts saw
an uptick in online chatter from
supporters of isis and al qaeda they
pointed to the violence as an example of
the kind of lone wolf attack that can be
carried out in the u.s homeland security
says the primary terrorism-related
threat to the u.s is from lone offenders
or small groups whose foreign or
domestic grievances are often driven by
online content the bulletin says recent
threats against historically black
colleges and universities as well as
jewish facilities and churches cause
concern and may inspire extremist threat
actors to mobilize to violence
on the timing this new advisory expands
on a security bulletin that was set to
expire today and while homeland security
says it's not aware of any imminent
incredible threats the bulletin says
domestic violent extremists remain
interested in disrupting the power grid
to create chaos nate
catherine thank you